[MUSIC PLAYING]
WARREN CHUEI: Hello, everyone.
Welcome to the webcast
on "API Innovation
with a Consumer Mindset."
First things first.
Just wanted to thank everyone
taking time out of your day
to join me to talk
about this topic.
So just to kick things off, a
brief introduction of myself.
My name is Warren Chuei.
I'm a global digital
advisor with Apigee.
More specifically, I work with
our Customer Success team.
So been with Apigee for,
god, almost seven years now.
During that entire
time, really working
a lot with our customers,
getting API programs started
from the ground up
and really working
with C-level executives, VPs,
directors on business strategy,
and even just from a delivery
aspect of getting API programs
started from scratch.
And so this topic in
particular is something that
is near and dear to my heart.
Super happy to spend
some time to talk
about it with you guys today.
In terms of topics and
what we wanted to cover,
you might have seen
this in the agenda,
as well, as part of the
description for this webcast.
But we really wanted to go
over different aspects of what
it means when it comes to a user
or a consumer-centric approach
to API design and
API innovation.
So more specifically, we wanted
to revisit the digital value
chain.
This might be something that
you might be familiar with,
so I promise I will only spend
just a few minutes revisiting
what the digital value chain is.
And more specifically,
what it means
in terms of the API consumer.
We're going to be talking
about the outside-in approach
and why it's better.
Dive a little bit into
developer engagement,
best practices to
promote API adoption,
examples of what we
see in the industry--
so this is kind of pertaining
to what I was mentioning before
of the experience
that we've had working
with the various
customers over the years,
of how they've approached
it and some common trends
that we've seen.
And also, just how to get
started from your perspective.
If you want to go
down this journey,
what are some of the
questions and things
to consider that you
need to think of as you
move into this approach?
And then last but
not least, we'll
spend a little bit of time
covering any questions
that you guys may have.
And to the best of my
ability, I will answer them.
So to get started,
and I mentioned
this when we were talking
about the topics as well.
So the digital value
chain is something
that Apigee has been
pitching for pretty
much my entire time that I've
been here with the company.
It is the bread-and-butter
way of how we explain the API
journey or how APIs relate
to the end-to-end kind
of lifecycle where all the
different systems that are
involved when it comes to APIs.
So if you've seen this before,
I apologize in advance.
I'm going to go over it
just really, really quickly.
But if you haven't,
I will give you
a brief overview,
because this is really
the foundation of the
subsequent conversation we'll
be having, specifically around
this whole concept of an API
consumer-centric
approach to APIs.
So I'm going to be
starting over from the left
and slowly moving
over to the right.
So at the leftmost bit,
you have your consumer.
So this is the end user, right?
These are the people
using the applications
that are powered by your APIs.
So a good way of
thinking about this,
if you look at it from
mobile apps perspective, this
is you and me.
These are people with our
iPhones or Pixel phones.
We're using applications
or mobile applications.
And those applications are
essentially powered by APIs.
So that's us.
That customer here is
referring to the end user.
When it comes to
apps and experiences,
that's what I was just
mentioning before.
That is the application itself.
That is the thing on
your phone where you go
and if you want to use payment,
bank payments, the weather
app, the news app, whatever
it is, that is the application
that we use.
And that application
is powered by APIs.
Now, who develops those
APIs is the developer,
which is the third item that
you see here on this list.
That application was
built by a developer,
and that developer powers their
application based off of APIs.
Or in this case, it's
called the API product,
which we'll get a little
bit into more details
later on in this webcast.
And that's really,
when we talk about API,
that's the core aspect
that we're talking
about from that perspective.
Those APIs are built
by an API team.
Now, now we're getting a
little bit into the developers
potentially in
your organization.
If you have an
API program, these
are the people building the
APIs for those developers
to build the apps
for the end consumer.
So you're starting to see
what we mean here when
we say the digital value chain.
They're all kind of
connected and all kind
of related in that sense.
And then, of course, you
know APIs themselves,
they've got to get the
data from somewhere.
And so that's where we
consider this the back end.
So this could be things like
databases or backend services,
things that you may want to
expose out to the developers,
or having that data,
that capability
exposed out to your developer,
but packaged up in an API.
So just to reiterate,
customer, end user.
End user uses the application.
Like in this case,
from my example,
like a mobile application.
Those applications are
built by the developer.
Those developers are using APIs.
In this case, this is when it
starts to come into your realm.
Start using your APIs to
power the applications
that they're building.
Those APIs are built
by an API team,
and then those APIs
and the API team
really are building APIs around
some sort of backend system
or backend service that you
may have in place already.
So the topic of
this webcast, we're
really going to be
focusing on what we
call the consumer of the API.
So you may have guessed
that already when
we're talking
about the consumer,
we're really talking
about the developer level
that you see here.
Now, when we talk
about API consumer,
you can break that up into
different subcategories.
In the context of
developers, they
could be external
developers, so this
could be a person working
out of their garage
and they're building some
revolutionary new application.
They have nothing really to
do with your organization.
They're not even
really considered
a partner of your organization.
But they may actually
use your APIs,
if your APIs are
open to the public,
to build some sort
of functionality
for some application
that they want
to roll out to the end user.
These can also be
partner developers,
so people that are external
to your organization,
but maybe like a
partner company that you
may work with to build
some sort of application,
a joint application
that you guys
want to roll out to provide
some value to your customers.
They can also even be
internal developers.
They're not really
listed here on the sheet.
But even internally, the
way that you can also
look at it as well is that
you may have an API programmer
or a team that builds APIs.
But your consumer is another
part of your organization,
building some sort of
internal application
to roll out to, whether
internally or even externally,
to your end consumers as well.
So as you can see here, when
we talk about the API consumer,
we really are talking about
the consumers of the API,
but those consumers can be
different people, both within
and outside of
your organization.
So when we talk about this whole
concept of a consumer approach,
these are kind of things where
you might want to ask yourself,
if you have an API program
established already,
have you heard of any
of this feedback before?
Things like the
API documentation
isn't documented very
well, or I'm having trouble
finding the APIs that are
pertaining to the application I
want to build.
Or the API just doesn't
do what I want it to.
Or I just cannot figure
out how an API works.
When we talk about a
user-centric approach
to API design and
API innovation,
this is really what
we want to focus on.
We want to start
addressing the fact
that what we see as API
programs that are successful
really do take a
consumer-centric or
user-centric approach
to how they design,
how they implement, how
they roll out their APIs.
So if you're hearing a lot
of these kind of feedback
within your own API
program, then you're
the target audience of who we
want to talk to, specifically
in the topics that we're
going to be covering later on.
So one of the reasons,
or how we explain
why you may be getting
the feedback that we just
talked about, is
this whole concept
of the inside-out and
outside-in approach to APIs.
So once again, I'm going to
revisit the digital value
chain in this case.
So when we talk
about inside-out,
this is when we start talking
about-- think of it in terms
of how you design an API.
Traditionally, if you look
at what I call the old school
model of API design, when you
start talking about API design
from a legacy perspective,
a lot of times what we see
is that a lot of our
customers start off
with an inside-out approach.
And so what I mean
by that m they
have some backend
service or some data
they think is
going to be useful.
And really, when they
start building APIs,
they're not really taking the
customer or the app developer,
in this case, the external
consumer, into account.
They're really just saying,
I have all this data.
I have all this goodness in
terms of backend services.
How do I just wrap
that into an API
and then just sort of roll
that out there for the masses
to consume?
It's this whole like, "build
it and they will come"
kind of approach to API design.
And what we see
happen is, they really
just kind of repackage
what the backend service
provides and just kind
of throw it out there.
Now, the problem with
this is that a lot
of times, the backend
services are complex.
They're not necessarily
straightforward or
self-explanatory when it comes
to understanding what it does,
even from a data perspective.
And so if I'm a person
within the organization,
it may make perfect sense.
But if I'm that
guy who's building
the application
in my garage and I
have no idea how your
backend services work,
you can see a
scenario here where
that becomes a little
bit of an issue, right?
If I'm just getting
an API that's
sort of like a data dump of
all these different fields
and data, I may have a hard time
understanding what exactly I
need to extract to get my
needs as an app developer out
of that.
And so that's this whole
inside-out concept.
Now, what we promote is sort
of the opposite of that.
This is the outside-in approach.
You guys are familiar
with this whole thing
of API-first method
of API design,
then this is sort
of related to that.
And really, what
we mean by that is,
when you're designing your APIs
or you're approaching the API
program, you kind of want to
think of it from the other way
around, the opposite
of inside-out.
Which would be
outside-in, obviously.
And what we mean by
that is, you really
want to start thinking
and putting yourself
in the shoes of the end user
and the application developer.
So a simple way of
thinking about it
was, put yourself in the shoes
of the application developer.
If I was the person building
the app, what sort of APIs
would I want to consume?
If I were to want the most
easy, self-explanatory API
to consume, what
would that look like?
And really taking that
mindset of saying what
are the needs of the end user?
What kind of applications and
data are they looking for?
And also, what do the
application developers
want in terms of how
to consume those APIs?
And that may or may not
correlate to the back end.
So I think this is where it
gets a little bit tricky.
Because a lot of
times, especially
if you're internal
within your organization
and you have a good
understanding of what
the backend services
provide, you
tend to want to go
for building out APIs
that you know the backend
service can accommodate.
Once again, I
mentioned API-first.
Where it becomes a little
bit difficult for some
of these teams and some
of these programmers
is that they have a hard time
decoupling from that model.
And so they may
approach outside-in
with best intentions, but they
always get into a position
where it's really just a
slightly better version
of the inside-out model.
What we want to
promote is really
just starting from a
blank slate and using
that as the starting point.
To some extent, just forgetting
all about your backend service
and saying, purely from an
application perspective,
what are some cool apps?
What are some cool
functionalities
that we think will be needed?
And then using that
as the jumping-off
point for your API design.
So once again, to emphasize
that I was talking about before,
your API consumers
are important.
And some of the things
to consider here
is, you really want to know
who your app developers are
and the applications
that they're building.
I already talked the inside-out
or an outside-in to death.
But once again, correlating with
this whole API-first mentality,
the API-first approach
to API design.
Easy to consume APIs--
I'm going to mention
this a little bit
later in the webcast,
but things about
like really taking a
hard look at your APIs.
And are they really
easy to understand,
if I were to just kind of go
in and look at those APIs?
Is it self-explanatory enough?
Do the field names make
sense on their own?
Do I need to read some sort of
long API description document
just to understand what
payload I'm receiving when I'm
making a call and vice versa?
You want to make the
onboarding process
simple and frictionless.
This is something, when I
talk about developer portal
later on, I'll cover
in greater detail.
But you want to make sure that
getting access to your APIs
is going to be a very smooth and
not a very convoluted process.
And then finally, build your
requirements to your consumers,
not based off of your
own requirements.
Really, this is once
again putting yourself
in the shoes of the app
developer and the end user
and building requirements
from that perspective,
rather than just, these
are what services we have.
What are the requirements
of just packaging it
up and getting it out there?
So we're going to touch a little
bit upon developer engagement.
This is all sort of
related to this ongoing,
stressing the importance of
the API consumer approach.
So of course, the
developer engagement
is key to the success
of your API program.
What does that require?
So these are the
three main pillars
that we see often
in the industry,
and this is something
that we promote heavily
with our customers.
First of all is this
concept of API products.
Now, I'm not going to go
into great detail of what
an API product is.
There's a lot of
documentation and videos,
and it's one of the core
foundations of Apigee
as a product, is the ability
of bundling up your APIs
into products.
But very high-level, 10,000-foot
description of what API
products are is that they're
essentially a bundle of APIs.
One way you can look at it, I
like to use the LEGO analogy.
If you guys are
building out LEGOs,
very rarely do you go and
buy LEGO pieces one by one
when you're creating something.
More often than not, you go
into a store and you buy a set,
and that set comes
with all the pieces
you need to build
whatever plane or boat
or whatever you want to build.
So you can think of API
products as that set.
It is a bundle of APIs.
In this case, it will be
the individual LEGO pieces.
But at the end of the
day, it's a bundle of APIs
to have some sort of
core functionality
that you are providing
to your application
developers and your consumers.
So having a great API product
methodology and rollout model
is key here.
The other bit is a
developer portal,
having some sort of
mechanism of communicating
out APIs, allowing the
developers to have a place
to go and register to
get access to your API,
as well as getting
documentation and all
those kind of cool
things to raise
some sort of an easy-to-use,
self-explanatory portal,
is another trend we see
as being very important.
And then also, when it comes
to developer enablement,
providing them
with the resources
that they need and
the support that
they need to be successful
in utilizing your APIs.
So when it comes to best
practices to promote adoption,
we have these four
main categories.
I'm going to deep
dive into each one
of these in just a little bit.
But those are acquisition,
documentation and onboarding,
self-service, and of course, the
support and ongoing maintenance
of your API consumers.
So when we talk
about acquisition,
these are the things
that we talk about.
This is, how do we get your
app developers onboarded
and how do we get
them using your APIs
and getting excited
to use your APIs?
So the first one is this concept
you may have heard about.
It's called the 5-5-5 Rule.
Long story short, within
the first 5 seconds,
you want to grab
their attention.
In the next 5 seconds, you
want to build interest.
And then in the next
5 minutes, empowering
them to build an actual
case of using your APIs.
So once again, this
is really emphasizing
getting them excited
about your APIs
and getting them able to quickly
understand your API program.
What is it trying to accomplish?
And really building out
a use case for those
APIs in a very, very
short amount of time.
That relates to some
of the other bullet
points you see here, such
as value proposition.
How do you showcase your APIs?
How do you go out and promote
these APIs and say, hey,
this is something you guys want
to use when you're building out
your applications.
Once again, the API market
is very, very competitive.
If you really think
about it, there
are a lot of different
APIs out there.
Potentially, you may
have competitors that
have their own API programs.
And if you're
really trying to win
over an external
application developer,
for example, having
the most simple-to-use,
robust API catalog
is really one where
you're going to win them over.
Once again, I keep going
back to this example
of the app developer that's
working out of the garage.
If they're building out
the next revolutionary app
and they're using
your APIs but they
have a lot of different
choices amongst you
and your competitors
of which APIs
they want to utilize to get the
data that they need, of course
they're going to be leaning
more towards the APIs
that are easier
to consume rather
the ones that are
more complicated
and a bit more confusing.
They're all about rolling
applications out very quickly,
and you really want to appeal
to that aspect of it, which
goes into that
fourth bullet point
here about making it
easy to get started,
making it frictionless.
And then the last one
is really just something
that we've seen a lot as
well, promoting hackathons.
This is something that we,
as Google, we do a lot,
as you may have heard.
But really just having
different mechanisms
of really getting people to
have hands-on experiences
with the APIs in
order to acquire them
as consumers for those APIs.
These are the key tenets
that we talk about.
The next one is
documentation and onboarding.
We're getting a little bit
into the developer portal now.
But really, what we're
talking about here--
first off, how do we engage
developers before registration?
This touches a little
bit upon the concept of,
a lot of times when it
gets access to APIs,
they're locked behind
this whole registration
wall where if I want to
even look into the APIs that
are available within a
person's organization,
I need to go through
this whole 5-
to 10-step process of
getting someone registered,
getting an API key, just to get
access to play around with it.
And we want to, however it makes
sense given your business case,
eliminate that model.
You want to start promoting
these APIs out there
to the public so that they
can get a good understanding
of the value or the
services that you're
providing without
jumping through hoops
to getting access.
Doesn't mean necessarily
that you're opening up access
to all your APIs to just
anyone in the public.
Once again, this really does
depend on your business case
and what services
you're providing.
But the more you can get
into this model of providing
open documentation or
descriptions of what services
you can provide, the
easier it's going to be
and the faster it's going to
be for those app developers
to really want to start
onboarding with your API
program.
When they do
eventually register,
you want to make sure that
registration process is
frictionless as well.
So this really goes
into the whole concept,
once again, of thinking
of, when it comes--
we were talking about API design
in the concept of API-first
or from the perspective of
an application developer.
This is the same thing,
just from a registration
point of view.
Your registration process
should be thought of of,
if I was an application
developer, what
sort of registration process
would I want to go through?
I guarantee you that everyone
wants a simpler registration
process rather than a
very complicated one that
takes a week to get an API key.
They want something quick,
they want something fast,
and they want something that's
very straightforward and easy
to take onboard with.
Self-service-- so once again, I
touched a little bit upon this
when I was describing
about API design early on.
But you want to make sure your
APIs are easy to understand.
We talked a little bit about
API products here as well.
You want to make
sure that, when it
comes to creating an application
or having them playing around
with your APIs, you want it to
be as self-explanatory as you
can possibly be.
And that can be looked at from
a variety of different ways.
You can look at it from how
these API request and response
payloads look like,
how simple are they
or how big the payloads are.
How granular the APIs
are, for example.
That's another way of doing it.
But really, it's
the concept of like,
if I'm building my
initial application
and I just wanted to
quickly play around
with your APIs, what's
the quickest, most
effective way of doing that?
And self-service,
self-explanatory kind of APIs
is definitely the model we
recommend as definitely the way
to go.
And the API programs
that we see our customers
have the most
success, those APIs
are very easy to
understand, just
reading a one- to
two-sentence description,
or even to some extent,
the API name itself.
Just reading-- if they can read
it and get a good understanding
of, oh, I know what this API
does, then the easier the
better.
And then there's also
this whole concept
of having them try this out.
This ties once again with the
whole registration process,
but also within the
capability of Apigee
as a product of being
able to call APIs
or doing test calls through
the portal itself is something
that we see a lot
of success with.
So if you can implement
something like that
and provide them with
some sort of "try it now"
feature within your
developer portal,
that is the ideal
method that we recommend
when it comes to the ease
of onboarding and the time
to get folks onboarded
onto your API program.
And last but not least,
support and maintenance.
This is the ongoing support,
once they are building
applications using your APIs.
What resources do they have in
case they run into roadblocks?
What kind of documentation?
What kind of guides do
they need to follow?
What sort of write-up?
Community-- we talk about this
whole concept of you building
out an API community where
you may have something
like a forum or a blog
or some sort of mechanism
where they can go in and
ask questions about like,
hey, I'm running into this
issue with consuming an API.
How do I get around it?
Or I'm getting a weird response.
Can someone please explain
to me what this response is?
And really, once again,
it's providing them
with the resources
that they need
to be successful in using
and consuming your API.
And this could be within your
developer portal, as well.
It could be part of a
maybe dedicated role
that you have, like an API
evangelist or some sort
of product owner.
But the other way of
looking at this, too,
is really just
having a mechanism
of capturing feedback.
Once your APIs
are rolled out, it
doesn't mean those APIs
will forever not be changed.
We have versioning we
want you to build out
your APIs in iterations
and constantly get
feedback from your API
consumers and app developers
so that you can further iterate
and enhance those APIs to cater
to the needs of where
your business is going
and, specifically, who's
consuming those APIs.
So here are some examples that
we've seen in the industry.
I personally have
seen a lot of this
with a lot of our
customers over the years,
when they're
talking about taking
this whole outside-in
approach, ease of use,
ease of onboarding.
These are some common trends.
I'm not going to
go into the details
of each one of these
mean, because that's
going to be different
webcasts and different topics
all on its own.
But I do recommend that,
if any one of these
are of interest to
you, definitely hit up
either our Apigee community
or our Apigee Docs page.
We have a lot of good
documentation on our website
that really deeps dive into a
lot of these different things,
whether they be industry
standards and industry
trends or very specific
product capabilities.
That can help you out with this.
So one of the trends that we
see is moving to RESTful APIs.
A lot of our
customers, specifically
those with API programs that
have been around for a while,
they usually come from kind
of a SOAP-based API model,
those with things like
XML payloads, for example.
And having that move
over to something
more RESTful,
something using JSON,
from a payload perspective.
That's one of the common
first steps we see,
where just making the
payload easier to read,
easier to use from a
consumer perspective.
With that, as well,
what we see a lot when
it comes to RESTful
APIs, and specifically
in the concept of
payloads, is that a lot
of times, when we
see with legacy APIs,
that sometimes these
payloads are huge.
They're giving them
basically all the data
within a specific
call, and just to comb
through all of that to get maybe
a specific field that the app
developer needs is
a tedious thing.
Using something like
the Apigee API Platform
to customize or to
adjust the payload based
on maybe some sort of entry
criteria or some sort of data
that they're passing as
part of the API request,
is things that they can
use to really either maybe
shorten or filter out certain
fields pertaining to what
the app developer wants to use.
So there's a lot of different
ways that you can approach it.
But just keep in mind that
once again, this whole concept
of, you want your APIs that
are self-explanatory but also
easy to consume, easy to
read, and easy to understand.
I talked about incorporating
methods of feedback.
Once again, blogs, forums,
having a dedicated role
to go in and ping your
application developers
and saying, hey, what's working?
What's not?
That is another way of really
allowing you to better steer
your API program in the
direction of consumability
and having this whole consumer
kind of approach to APIs,
so that when you're
investing your time
and resources of building
that next version of the API,
you don't want to just
shoot in the dark.
You really want to base
it off some hard data,
some hard feedback, both
positive and negative,
that you're getting
from the people actually
using your APIs.
We talked about
developer portal already.
But once again, utilizing it
in a very effective manner when
it comes to the
registration process, when
it comes to documentation, when
it comes to this whole "try it
now" feature with APIs.
Things like that.
This one's an interesting one.
The whole role of
an API evangelist--
a lot of times, we don't
see this role when--
especially with our
newer customers.
This is sort of a new role
that only a select handful
of our customers have
pre-established before really
rethinking their API program.
And what we mean
about API evangelists
is sort of like the person
who promotes the API.
So this could be someone
who goes out and maybe hosts
the hackathons or really
reaches out to your application
community and saying, hey, look,
these are all the cool new APIs
that are being developed.
This is why you want
to use these APIs.
And really, someone
to promote those APIs
is the purpose of this role.
And a lot of times,
this role is also
combined with the person who's
the direct person getting
the feedback.
When we talk about the feedback,
the second bullet point here,
that's also kind of related
to that role as well.
Simplifying the API
registration process.
Once again, we talked
about that already.
But you want it to be
as simple as possible.
You don't want it to be a
one-week, two-week process
of running through
manual approvals
and sending emails
just to get an API key.
If you can make
this self-service,
do a thing like a
developer portal.
Make it within seconds
to get an API key
rather than a very manual
process that takes time.
The faster, the better,
and the easier the better.
And then once again, this
move to API products.
Once again, it just makes
understanding the APIs easier
if you were to take a whole
product or a productization
or a product-centric
approach to it.
Because once again, going
back to the LEGO analogy,
it's a little bit
easier to understand
when it's bundled in the context
of a specific functionality
or a specific group so that
people can say, oh, yeah.
That's the API
product I want to use,
because that is the one closest
tied to the application I
want to build.
So let's say you want to
start getting started.
Let's say that, going all the
way back to one of the earlier
slides, that you are getting
a lot of this feedback
that your API program has
APIs that are hard to use.
Or just people are just having
a hard time understanding
how your APIs work, or it's a
very high-touch kind of model
where you need to constantly
work with their app developers
just to get them onboarded have
them start consuming your APIs
and understanding your APIs.
These are the common questions
that we ask our customers,
and you probably want to start
asking yourself, and really
taking a hard look at your API
program and really saying, OK,
how do we start down this
path of getting to that model
that we want to get to?
This whole outside-in model.
One is identifying, who
are my API consumers
and what applications
are they building?
Once again, this is really
having a good understanding
of who's actually
consuming your APIs.
It's definitely the first start.
If you have no idea who's using
your APIs, that is a problem.
And so you want to
start addressing, really
understanding who's
consuming your APIs, how
they're consuming it,
and what kind of feedback
that they have.
The other one is, how
self-explanatory are the APIs?
How easy are they to understand?
We talked about RESTful
earlier on as well.
When it comes to
payloads, when it
comes to API naming conventions,
is it straightforward enough?
If I had no idea what
the backend systems did,
would I still be able
to piece together
what an API could do based
specifically just on the name
alone?
Things like that.
Do I have a developer portal
ready to support my community?
Once again, developer
portal is just
the tool, a mechanism to
interact with your application
developers.
So we highly recommend you
utilize something like that.
We've seen a lot of success
in having a developer
portal be that mechanism, be
that tool for your developers.
What does your developer
onboarding process look like?
Once again, make it simple.
Make it automated, if it
makes sense for your business.
The most common example we see
here for a developer onboarding
process, this is very much
like how when you register
for like an online
store, providing you
with your email, maybe
some basic information.
I will shoot you an
automated email confirmation,
just to confirm it's
a real email address.
And once that's done, bam.
The registration
process is done and you
can log in and start reading
documentation and potentially
even making some API calls.
If you can get to
that kind of model,
that's a really good
model to get to,
just because it's very
easy and it's very quick.
Within a matter of
seconds, really, I
can start reading up
on API documentation
and getting access to start
playing around with your APIs.
That ties a little bit
into the fifth point
here, which is how
quickly can developers
obtain an API key, as well.
Where will developers
get answers
when they encounter issues?
So this is the whole ongoing
support and maintenance
that we talked about earlier.
And then finally,
what KPIs will I
track to determine what
success looks like?
So this is more of a kind
of an internal thing.
But just to touch a
little bit about KPIs.
And once again, there's a lot
of good documentation on KPIs
that are out there on
our Apigee website,
so I encourage
you to look there.
But when we talk
about KPIs here,
we're talking about
things like the number
of active developers.
Not the number of developers.
The number of active
developers who are consistently
using your APIs--
the number of useful APIs.
A lot of times, we
see our customers
think if they have 900 APIs that
shows a successful API program.
We disagree.
It's not about the number
of APIs, but it's about,
do you have a core
set of APIs that
can pertain to a lot of
different API products
and a lot of
different applications
that can be easily reused for
a lot of various business cases
and use cases and
things like that?
That is more useful than just
the sheer number of APIs.
And then also, of course, the
speed of onboarding traffic
growth, direct revenue.
There's a lot of different
ways of measuring the KPIs,
but that's one thing you
want to keep in mind is,
what are the KPIs
for your API program?
And how does that tie back
into this whole concept
of a user-centric approach?
So once again, these
are just questions
to consider that you
want to ask yourself.
There are a lot of different
ways that you can approach it.
But as long as you can
approach it, once again,
from this outside-in model,
that is something that we--
the purpose of this
webcast is really
to stress that in particular.
All right, so that is just the
high-level overview of what
we wanted to talk
about when it comes
to this whole kind of
user-centric application,
consumer-centric
approach to APIs.
Once again, I've
only touched upon it
at a very, very high level.
I hope what you've
taken away from this
is how we think of an
outside-in type approach, what
are some of the
key things that we
think are very, very important.
We've only already
touched a little bit
at a very high level what our
other customers have done,
but you can hopefully have
seen the common trends
of at least the approach
that they took when it comes
to things like
RESTful API design,
when it comes to things like
utilizing developer portal,
and just even in terms of the
mentality of how they switch
when it comes to
API design, shifting
the mentality from an inside-out
model to an outside-in model.
So with that, I can see that we
already have a couple questions
already.
So I'm going to do my best
to get through all of them.
If I don't get a chance to
get through all the questions,
I definitely will answer
them either offline
either after the session is
done or within the chat itself.
So if I don't get
to your question,
I do apologize in advance.
But I will get to as
many of these as I can.
First question that
I can see here.
"Can you elaborate on
the RESTful approach
and how it ties to the
whole outside-in model?"
Yeah.
So RESTful approach,
kind of what
I was talking about in
the middle of this webcast
is this whole concept of, how
self-explanatory are the APIs?
So those of who
are not familiar,
the whole concept of
a RESTful approach
is really things like
they have a certain way
of doing like naming conventions
and things like that.
And really, that's what
we wanted to emphasize.
From an API--
I'll start with
naming convention.
Are the APIs named in such a
way where I can very easily
understand what the API can do?
So this whole concept of
like the whole post and put
and delete and the
verbs and all that.
Really, the whole
RESTful approach
is really to get
to that model where
there is a kind of a universal
common understanding of what
an API can do, just
based off the name alone.
So that's what I mean by
ease of use for the API,
following a RESTful approach.
All right, other question.
"What do you mean when you
talk about API products?"
Yeah, so just to reiterate,
when I talk about API products,
once again, this is about
the bundling of the APIs
using that whole LEGO analogy
that I talked about earlier.
API products-- and I
mentioned this before.
It is really a core part of how
Apigee as a platform is built.
We lean heavily into this
whole concept of API products,
because the way that we
see it is that if you can--
there's one thing to
have an API catalog.
But API products is
just another mechanism
of-- if you take
a productization
approach or a way of
thinking of your APIs,
then really, you're
starting to think
about packaging those
APIs to maybe one day
get even to a
monetization type model
where you're charging your
consumers per API call.
And really, the
concept behind that
is, you want to start
thinking of APIs
as, I have a lot of useful data.
There are people internal,
external within our company
that wants to have
access to that data
because they can use that
data in a lot of cool ways
with their applications.
How do I expose that
data out in APIs?
And if you can think about
it from a product model,
like as if you're trying
to sell those APIs
and there's some sort
of monetary return
you're going to
get for those APIs,
that really is putting
you in the right mindset
of how you want to think
about when you're exposing how
your APIs.
If you're thinking from
that perspective of I
have useful data, but how do
I roll it out in such a way
where people will want
to pay money to use that,
then that's definitely the
first step into a model
that you want to get into
that leads to a successful API
program.
So long story short, that's
what we talk about API products.
Once again, how it correlates
as you are thinking in terms of,
as an app developer,
I really want
to get access to that cool data
that you have in your back end.
How would I want to make those
calls, as an app developer,
putting yourself in their shoes.
Next question.
"When it comes to
the developer portal,
should I start off big or can
it be iterated over time?"
Great question.
Personally, what I've seen
is the iteration approach,
and that is the approach
that I would recommend.
You're not going to get your
developer portal perfect.
And this goes the same with
APIs themselves as well.
You're not going to get
it right on the first try.
There's going to be feedback
that you're going to get.
And what you want to avoid
probably most importantly
is, you don't want to
spend so much time trying
to create the perfect
developer portal
with the perfect
registration process
that you elongate
your time to market.
You want to roll something
out there very quick.
It may not have all the bells
and whistles, for example,
like developer portal.
It may not have a blog
or a forum capability
to get right from
the start, but you
want to roll it
out with your APIs,
and you want to roll
them out quickly
because you want to start
gathering that feedback as
quickly as possible.
So in this case, I definitely
would recommend that,
in my opinion, as
long as you can
get very easy-to-use kind
of registration process,
maybe some look and feel tweaks
and some good documentation up
and running, start
with the basics.
Start from there and
iterate over time
is definitely the
way that I would go.
One thing that ideally
you would want to avoid
is rolling out the APIs
in some sort of mechanism,
god forbid it being some sort
of like 300-page API document
or something like that
that you have to email over
to all your app developers.
The more quickly
you can roll out
a developer portal,
the better, in my mind.
But that was a great question.
All right, let's see.
"You mentioned capturing
feedback from consumers.
What are some examples
of how that can be done?"
Once again, another
great question.
I'm going to go back to
the developer portal here.
A lot of times when
it comes to feedback,
it can be done through forms.
If you have this idea
of implementing a form,
that could be one mechanism.
On the developer portal itself,
there could be a feedback link.
We talked about the role
of the API evangelist
or maybe a product owner
or someone who can maybe
proactively reach out to
application developers
and get feedback there.
The importance
here is not only do
you want to capture
feedback, and there's
a lot of different ways, as I
just described, of doing that,
but you want to make sure that
there is a process that you
build into your API program
and your software delivery
lifecycle of, how do
we take that feedback
and incorporate it into the
next iteration of the API?
I think that's the trick here.
I think there's a lot of
times when people go down
this approach, they think about
how to capture the feedback,
but they don't really think
about how to act upon it.
So when you're starting
to think about things
like-- for example, we promote
an Agile type methodology when
it comes to API development.
The reason we promote that
is because with something
like Agile or an iterative
approach to development,
you can very quickly
turn on a dime
and implement new feature
requests or new feedback you're
getting much more
quickly than if you
were to do something like in a
waterfall-type delivery model.
So it's sort of all
related to that.
You just want to make
sure that there's
a good mechanism of getting that
feedback back to your product
owners and your API
developers, just so
that they can act upon it.
That's another great
question as well.
So given the amount
of time we have left,
this is probably the last
question I'll answer live,
and then we will maybe jump
into answering the rest
of the questions via chat.
Let's see.
"Is the developer portal
for external users only?"
OK, that's a great question.
In my mind, and this is what
I tell my customers as well,
your developer portal
should not differentiate
between internal and external.
And what I mean by that is--
and this kind of goes
into the whole philosophy
of your API design as well.
You don't want to
design an API for--
oh, these APIs are
for external consumers
and I'm going to design my
internal APIs differently.
From the end of
the day, you want
to look at your API
consumers as one entity.
Because at the end
of the day, everyone,
whether they be internal
or external application
developers within
your organization,
wants APIs that are easy to use.
They want to get access to the
APIs in a quick and efficient
manner.
So you should always
approach it and always
try to strive to make your APIs
as easy to consume as possible,
regardless of if they are an
external partner or a person
working at building an
application in their garage,
or the person just sitting
on the opposite side
of the building.
You have much more
flexibility, of course,
if there are internal
applications,
because maybe those
application developers already
understand the backend services
and what that pertains.
But you don't want to go
down the path of building
kind of two different
versions of the same API, one
for internal, one
for external, if you
have the option of building one
API that both parties can use.
From a maintainability,
it's a lot easier.
But also just in terms
of happy app developers.
Once again, putting
yourself in the shoes of,
what can I do to make
their lives a lot easier so
that they can go build their
applications much quicker.
That is the approach
you want to take.
So developer portal falls
in that same line as well,
to directly answer
your question.
When you're building
out a developer portal,
a lot of times, we
tell our customers
that they should build
one developer portal.
Now, what the person can
see in that developer portal
in terms of what APIs
are available to them,
that's where something like
role-based access control
will come in.
As an external person
using the developer portal,
I may not see all the APIs that
an internal user would see,
but it should still
be one portal.
Ideally, you won't want
to get into a scenario
where you have to maintain and
upkeep two separate developer
portals, from a cost and
operations perspective.
So with that, I think that
is a wrap for the webcast.
So once again, thank you so
much for spending the time today
with me to go over this topic.
Once again, it's
something that we
see a lot with our customers.
It's the ongoing message that we
promote a lot with our customer
base.
So I really hope that
you found this useful.
I hope that some of the
questions we brought up,
some of the topics
that we talked about,
will get you thinking
about where you're
at with your API program.
And more importantly,
how you want
to get to that ideal
state of having
this whole user-centric
approach to your APIs.
And once again, if there
are any questions you have,
definitely reach out.
We have a very robust
kind of community
to answer your questions.
Once again, I
mentioned before, we
have a very great and robust
documentation site for Apigee
that not only goes through
all the Apigee capabilities,
but also even concepts like
RESTful API design, versioning,
and all of these
different things.
Developer portal, for example.
So I highly recommend
you guys take a look at
that if that interests you.
So that's a wrap on the webcast.
So once again, thanks again.
And I hope you guys
have a great day.
[MUSIC PLAYING]